[Music]
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker are you spiderman's
girlfriend
are you spiderman's girlfriend
please don't touch her you're just a kid
well i'll tell you what i call him
public enemy number one
dude
you ready
i'm ready
nice knowing you spiderman excuse me
the entire world's about to forget that
peter parker is spiderman everyone
uh can't some people still know that's
not how the spell works so my
girlfriend's just gonna forget about
everything we've been through i mean is
she even gonna be my girlfriend all
right fine okay
everyone in the world is gonna forget
that you're spiderman except your
girlfriend thank you so much that
oh my god next okay let's not change the
parameters of this spell anymore while
i'm okay i'm done i'm done i swear i'm
done i'm done
now but my auntie should really know you
just stop talking
hello peter
hi
[Music]
[Applause]
do you want to play games
catch
[Music]
don't worry ma'am i'm coming
[Music]
give me the box
[Music]
[Music]
what is this place the mirror dimension
where i'm in control strange stop can we
please just talk about this parker don't
you realize that in the multiverse there
are an infinite number of people who
know peter parker is spider-man and if
that spell gets loose they're all coming
here look i know i get it but we can't
just send them home to die it's their
fate
you can't change that anymore then you
can change who they are
oh what are you doing
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby-doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
but there has to be another way there
isn't
there are danger to our universe
you know to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
and everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
we down here in georgia baby down here
in georgia
with some creativity you can shoot
almost anything here in atlanta we have
all our stages here they've taken such
good care of us we are so lucky to be
here
there's a great crew here there are
facilities here there's equipment here
the vendors are fantastic
the scale of what they have is not to be
underestimated and to see it grow and
evolve each year
it's great badass and it's amazing to
have a single home where we can have
three or four productions going on at a
time the quality of the set build the
paint work the effect just puts you
right back on your game full credit to
the set designers and all the crew that
have just made it look incredible i
can't believe i'm in the sanctum
sanctorum
there's not a lot of states where you
can do that where they have the
facilities and they have the equipment
to manage that level of production you
won't know that it's not in new york
when you see it
[Applause]
[Music]
we started getting some visitors from
every universe hello peter it's been
very nice to come back to something that
is familiar but at the same time
completely new you're not be the poker i
am so confused right now 20 years since
his green goblin
17 years since my first time as doc what
was your name again dr otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name we got
another chance to stir some things up
oh you like the noodle electro is like
the world did me wrong now i got this
energy i'm about to go get mine you're
not gonna take this away from me
picks up where he left off what have you
done with my machine he's looking for
revenge do you want to play games
the goblin believes in a world of losers
and winners power is all that matters
[Music]
it's a wonderful world to be in we're
having a lot of fun they're a danger to
our universe we need to send them back
it looks like we got competition
i think people are going to be really
surprised they're going to marvel
oh
[Music]